si vous étiez donc dans les
embouteillages de retour d'un long et du
week-end de l'ascension
hier voici donc ce que vous avez
peut-être raté et ce qui s'est passé sur
tf1
un peu après 20 heures ces élections
c'est un échec
c'est pas facile mais il faut le
reconnaître avec humilité c'est un échec
et au fond pour le dire assez simplement
les victoires elles sont collectives les
défaites elles sont solitaires c'est
comme ça il faut que je prenne mes
responsabilités ma décision ce soir
c'est une décision qui est mûrement
réfléchi j'ai décidé de prendre du recul
et pour répondre à votre question je me
retire de mes fonctions de président des
républicains
alors depuis cette déclaration depuis ce
coup de théâtre
un mot revient en boucle digne dignité
ce sont les comme ça qu'on qualifie chez
beaucoup de républicains
la façon dont fait partie la décision
qu'a prise
laurent wauquiez est ce que ces
réactions vous les trouvez digne
précisément richard oui elles sont dits
dans ce moment parce que personne ne va
dire exactement ce qu'il pense de la
prestation de laurent wauquiez hier soir
je pense que au delà des micros et au
delà des tweets on aura peut-être des
gens qui vont dire enfin parce que la
décision peut être prise un peu tard
d'autres qui diront c'était quand même
bien joué mais c'est un peu surjouée
dans la manière de se mettre en scène
dans la manière de venir le dire sur un
plateau de télé on ne sait pas d'où vous
près d'un bureau des républicains ce pas
dit dans une assemblée avec les élus
républicains s'est dit à la télé comme
ça bon oui il ya un petit peu du laurent
wauquiez dans son départ je trouve bien
mais aux écoutes est à l'essai à l'issue
d'un bureau politique des républicains
il ya une semaine et quelqu'un et je me
souviens malheureusement plus de qui a
eu cette parole absolument féroce et a
dit on à une réunion de famille s'était
société des obsèques
malheureusement le mort parlait et bien
le mort a parlé sur tf1 on a entendu le
mort parler peut-être at-il tenu une
semaine dans cet état mais oui il n'y
avait pas d'autres pas d'autre issue me
semble-t-il est de toute façon
d'accord est ce que vous trouvez que un
c'est la façon dont il l'a fait et aussi
digne que l'on dit les réactions et
trouvé que les réactions qu'ils ont
qualifié de digne cette décision le sont
vraiment rien d'un digne ni dans la
forme qu'il a utilisée ni dans les
commentaires par contre quelqu'un qui
pendant 59 minutes de sa vie politique a
été férocement orléaniste et puis la
dernière minute s'est découvert
bonapartiste et patriote
oui ces scènes ça ne passait pas ça ne
passe guère effectivement nicolas
c'était quand on sait que par rapport à
d'autres pays en france les politiques
démissionnera mans et ils ont aussi la
mauvaise habitude de revenir sur la
scène politique alors qu'ils ont fui les
échecs cuisants
je dirais oui c'est effectivement dean
mais c'est pas ça ce qui est plus
inquiétant c'est ce qui est inquiétant
c'est la succession dans les idées alors
voir ça je vous laisse remettre votre
micro qui viennent de tomber
mais vous inquiétez pas on va régler ça
jacki vous le spécialiste en
communication
comment vous allez trouver la faune le
fond la forme et les réactions à la
différence benoît hamon qui a été
contraint de se mettre en retraite de
son mouvement et personne n'a vu benoît
hamon prendre la parole au tèf un
batteur qui est quand même la sacro
sainte messe à laquelle tout le monde
peut accéder
laurent wauquiez a eu quand même droit à
un temps de parole sans doute au moment
du journal télévisé le plus regardé de
france de ce point de vue là il a encore
un statut dans les médias qui lui a
permis de s'offrir un enterrement en
grandes pompes pour profiler un peu
comme ça votre métaphore donc c'est pas
c'est pas un coup réussi parce que
d'annoncés est effectivement sa propre
mort à l'ensemble du peuple français
c'est jamais très agréable mais d'un
point de vue du statut qui peut lui être
accordée par les journalistes ou pas il
aurait très bien pu refuser de de
l'accueillir c'est plutôt pas mal
après derrière vous allez ouvrir sans
doute un tas d'autres fenêtres c'est que
c'est la 5e ou 6e déconvenue d'un
un parti qui a offert cinq présidents
lors de la 5ème république donc ça c'est
très préoccupant alors soit autant
parler hélas hélas nous dit nicolas
lecaussin justement pour savoir s'il ya
des chances de survie pour pour laurent
wauquiez c'est peut-être un sujet d un
sujet de débat d'abord il ya de la
question du jour par contre c'est sûr là
sur les républicains y at il un espace
politique pour la droite entre l om et
le rassemblement national c'est la
question que vous pouvez trouver sur
lefigaro.fr vous pouvez continuer à
répondre pour l'instant vous êtes une
légère majorité à répondre non voici en
tout cas en attendant ce que propose
pour la suite
le l'ancien ministre et député eric
woerth
on y revient juste après je souhaite
l'installation d'une véritable
collégialité qui représente abattre 25
personnes qui représentent la république
1 et qui intègre aussi un titre ou un
autre dans toutes les
toutes les responsabilités l'ensemble
des générations il ya plein de jeunes
députés extrêmement talentueux on a
besoin de reconstruire ensemble la
droite et pas au profit d'un tel ou d'un
tel pas au profit de telles ambitions
c'est très bien les ambitions l'info en
politique comme ailleurs
mais là si on n'a pas une droite
crédible on n'aura pas de candidat
crédible
guillaume bigot c'est une bonne idée ce
que propose donc je crois pas je pense
que ce que nous appelions dans le champ
politique la droite et la gauche
il faut le il faut vraiment profondément
le réinventer que ceux qui prennent la
place de la droite de l'ex droite soit
maintenant la gauche ce qui prennent la
place de l'ex gauche on attend la droite
qu'importe
qu'importe finalement le le flacon seul
le breuvage va compter il a à force
d'essayer de faire revivre en fait un
clivage qui est qui est complètement
date et c'est vraiment 7,7 cette image
des personnages ans et dessins animés
qui sont au dessus d'un d'un ravin et
puis il met un certain temps avant de
tomber
vous pensez comme cet internaute qui
nous dit wauquiez aurait dû dissoudre
tout le parti dans la foulée des
républicains sont morts c'est pas sa
responsabilité à lui il peut pas
vraiment au stade le constat le constat
le constat de décès ou le voudrez fait
au delà du parti lui même des
républicains
c'est plus profondément encore le
clivage lui même tel qu'il est sorti de
1789 à droite ou de 1792 à droite ceux
qui veulent la mort du roi au plus tôt
ce qu'ils veulent épargner le roi merci
du lapsus et à gauche ceux qui veulent
la mort du roi
et bien maintenant qu'elle est le roi ou
et finalement le le souverain a décapité
est-ce que c'est pas l'euro par exemple
c'est une question que je pose on peut
et on peut y revenir juste quand même
sur cette question de la suite
richard going
vous qui avez été enfin qui avait vu un
petit peu le cas du parti socialiste
après la déflagration pour le coup de
2017 et la déconvenue de benoît hamon
est-ce que
vous pensez que ce que propose eric
woerth est une bonne idée et qu'est-ce
que vous conseillerez on regarde ce que
vous avez vu au ps aux républicains moi
je sais pas s'il ps et celui qui doit
conseiller les républicains demain moi
je suis un peu plus nuancé sur la
disparition du clivage droite gauche il
apparaît effectivement facialement sur
les dernières élections européennes
c'est un peu plus compliqué si en fait
il y avait pas la guerre des ego à
gauche
les études qui ont été faites montrent
que les électorats notamment de yannick
jadot de benoît hamon et les deux heures
a fait avec duke semaine sont des
électorats très proches les uns des
autres
c'est une étude de la fondation jean
jaurès est repris par ses reprises je
finis par gilles finchelstein qu'il a
très bien mis en exergue dans un dans un
édito on a des aspirations qui sont très
proches mais on a des ego qui sont très
forts de la part de l'ensemble des
responsables politiques et qui font
qu'il n'ya pas eu à un moment donné de
rassemblement à gauche mais le bloc
gauche c'est un blog qui existent sur la
france un smith je ne rentre pas dans le
bloc gauche parce que sur la barre trop
haut sur l'avenant j'attends ma gauche
macro nien vous me connaissez
suffisamment mal pour pouvoir penser que
ma gauche et macro nian mais plus un
port ne sais pas vous mais j'ai pas les
moyens de vous parler non c'est pas une
gauche macro nien je crois qu'il ya un
espace aujourd'hui entre la france
insoumise et emmanuel macron comme je
crois qu'il ya un espace entre emmanuel
macron qu'est le rassemblement national
ce que je dis qu'aujourd'hui s'est
brouillé pour les raisons que vous avez
évoqué rapidement qui est que l'optique
idéologique sur la vraie dent se
construit n'est plus aujourd'hui quelque
chose de clair mais ça veut pas dire que
l'espace politique n'existe pas c'est ce
que pense à vous inscrire oui oui mais
si je reviens votre question originelle
est ce qu'il faut voir c'est que ça fait
un moment que la droite est en train de
mourir lorsque copé fillon
livre un spectacle absolument calamiteux
la droite enregistre sa première
déstabilisation puis après l'autre chose
sur lequel ils devront travailler et
c'est pour ça que ça sa proposition est
intéressante il a dit autre chose
d'intéressant eric woerth il a dit avant
de dire qu' il faut dire quoi c'est que
les républicains ils se sont fait pomper
leur doctrine rappelez-vous ce qu'on
reprochait emmanuel macron un moment on
a dit ce type là il n'a pas de doctrine
et dans les partis ne pas avoir de
doctrine généralement on n'est pas trop
habitué c'est un canard sans pattes ça
n'existe pas et lui il a quand même
conquis le pouvoir en ayant 0 doctrine
il a fait juste en exprimant le fait qu'
il croyait à quelque chose à un projet
sa révolution
mais il n'avait pas de doctrine installé
là les républicains ils se sont faits
mais déchiré l'ensemble de leurs grands
axes d'un séminaire c'est ce que dit la
vidéo jusqu'au bord d'années dans le
clivage gauche droite est peut-être
dépassé mais si on observe la politique
de macron depuis deux ans elle séduit
les élus depuis oui mais mais mais la
droite elle a perdu sa sofo doctrinaire
depuis cette querelle entre copé et
fillon et ça ça doit nous interroger au
delà du reste après bien je pense que ce
qu'ils font assez bien c'est de savoir
gérer les querelles d'ego aujourd'hui
ils sont au 36e sous sol ils vont pas
commencer à proposer à leurs militants à
savoir qui de pécresse de bertrand qui
est pas complètement la de l'archer qui
a des ambitions que de woerth qui
semblait légitime
on n'en est pas là et je pense pas à ça
qu'il faut ça tandis que la cet attelage
digne du parti communiste chinois est
proposé
je garde ça vous plaît ou pas non il
faut ce qu'il faut ce qui ce sont les
idées on a comparé à l'iref les
programmes des partis en lice pour les
européennes et elle est programmée sur
bellamy
il y avait un peu de tout il y avait un
peu de quelque chose de macron de
rassemblement national d'écolo de
c'était comme un plat comme ça on avait
mis plein des pis y'a pire et aucun goût
donc ce qu'il faut pour la droite moi -
la personne sont les idées si la droite
a perdu c'est parce qu'elle ne s'est pas
présentée comme une vraie droite
libérale conservatrice la guerre ce qui
s'est passé en australie
regardez ce qui s'est passé l'année
passée ou aux pays bas regardez ce qui
se passe dans d'autres dans d'autres
pays où la droite aux prises de vue
c'est de travailler ce qui sont arrivés
en tenons mais l'année passée et un 2017
la droite a gagné sans problème à
libéral mark rutte a gagné sans
problèmes en australie personne ne s'y
attendait ils ont leur idée libérale
conservatrice et un écologiste
il faut être sincère est affiché à
baisser alors justement je voudrais
qu'on rebondisse sur une autre
proposition qui a été faite cette social
était en embuscade
une heure avant laurent wauquiez s'était
toujours sur le groupe tf1 décidément à
la pointe hier soir aujourd'hui vu la
situation et tout ce dont je viens de
vous parler sur leur chiper lisation et
les fractures l'antagonisme l'incapacité
à reconstruire quelque chose ensemble
une espèce de france pour tous d'une
certaine manière
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de contribuer à
mon petit niveau je suis pas en mesure
de vous dire que je serai là à tel
endroit
mais en tout cas si je peux être utile
d'une manière ou d'une autre à un moment
donné précisément pour pour essayer de
construire cette grande alliance des
droites je le ferai à mon niveau si ça
peut être alors qu'en pense le
souverainiste guillaume bigot et snow
penser que c'est crédible et
est ce que vous y croyez je propose à la
fois oui non d'abord parce qu'on
pourrait se trouver ça très surprenant
macro n'ya oui et non c'est pas en même
temps c'est quoi en même temps reconnaît
m non vous allez voir sur mario maya oui
oui à quoi et non à quoi c'est toute la
question
oui au bloc patriotique oui au bloc
patriotique oui aussi à la personnalité
parce que c'est quelqu'un de 2,2
lumineux qui à la fois une une séduction
une langue extrêmement clair elle parle
de manière laconique et elle parle à mon
avis elle est capable de parler à
travers les classes sociales ce qui est
extrêmement rare
pour quelqu'un pour un homme politique
et à laisser quelqu'un ici qui est
capable de ne pas parler ce qui est
encore plus rare pour les hommes ou les
femmes politiques
donc cette femme a des qualités
éminentes indiscutablement quelles que
soient ses ascendants familiaux sont pas
nécessairement à mon sens très glorieux
mais qu'importe je reviens sur elle le
bloc patriotique oui maintenant elle
retombe un peu dans cette ornière de la
gauche et droite je ne veux pas
considérer qu'il n'y a pas de de jeu
politique bien sûr qu'il ya du jeu
politique bien sûr qu'il ya des nuances
comme vous disiez très justement les
chars brigue il y à des nuances mais la
question n'est pas tellement de celles
de senior en politique ce qui est
important c'est déterminer ses ennemis
ou ses adversaires en tout cas la
question n'est pas tellement ce qui il
ya toujours des choses qui vous
distingue mais globalement quel est
votre adversaire centrale
quel est votre cause centrale c'est ça
la question or le bloc patriotique elle
l'a bien identifiés d'un côté ceux qui
sont contre l'europe et là on mettra la
france insoumise dedans et on mettrait
toutes sortes de nuances qui ne sont pas
représentés aujourd'hui et de l'autre
les gens qui sont pour l'europe quelles
que soient leurs nuances et en effet
elles sont très importants de
saignements votre point de vue sur cette
question
les très maline bon et c'est ce qui se
passe ailleurs mais attention
est ce que deux libéral cause est séduit
par ses débuts pas ses idées libérales
mais attention la deûle à lille
le rassemblement national marine le pen
en france c'est complètement différent
de nigel farrage de même durban
sauf sur les ide et d'immigration les
programmes économiques n'ont strictement
rien à voir il ya un gouffre nigel
farrage elie balle et très libérale et
pour libre échange et seul un g vain
mais il était libérable ces deux points
de vue quand même donc et je suis crois
pas du tout à ce que à ce que dit
richard b du bon j'imagine ce que vous
pensez est-ce que vous pensez que ça ça
peut être une alternative crédible à
droite est ce que vous pensez que c'est
là il ya justement un espace qui
pourraient être retrouvées par les
républicains est un espace alternatif
avec cette espèce de bloc des gauches en
la france insoumise que vous évoquez en
tout cas elle et elle est celle qui
vient rebattre le plus à droite les
cartes avec sa sortie médiatique
elle arrive une semaine après une
victoire du rassemblement national aux
élections européennes capri 500 mille
voix par rapport aux élections
précédentes certes c'est dû en partie à
la participation mais quand même
elle arrive donc à un moment donné où
elle se pose qui en une alternative au
moment où on pense que ce parti a réglé
une partie de son problème de leadership
avec avec marine le pen qui fait une
élection où elle est très présente et où
finalement elle l'emporté marion
maréchal revient à ce moment là elle
revient sans le savoir mais au moment où
je sais les républicains c'est très
fragile et ça fait une semaine que ça
tangue pas mal et elles arrivent en
disant je suis une alternative possible
parce qu'elle sent bien le jeu politique
parce qu elle est maligne effectivement
et qu'elle a bien senti qu'il y avait un
espace aujourd'hui entre un plafond de
verre qui n'en est pas un du côté du
rassemblement national mais qui pourrait
en être un à une présidentielle les
républicains qui vont prendre du temps
pour se reconstruire parce que
indéniablement aux municipales ça va
être compliqué de ressortir un parti
très uni et très construit et l arrivée
notre sort à l'an prochain non je ne
suis pas serein pour l'an prochain je ne
pense pas que je ne pense pas qu'on
puisse être dans une mode de sérénité je
pense qu'il ya des cartes qui se
rebellent met aujourd'hui regardez
l'inquiétude de beaucoup d'élus les
républicains qui disait que en gros il
allait aux municipales avec un parti qui
posais pas mal de questions sur on va ça
mon niveau en alliance on n'y va pas en
alliant son on peut se faire élire ou
pas bref ya une question elle arrive
elle est trahie mais elle arrive dans un
moment je trouve très malin c'est le
moment où le rassemblement national est
en hausse et où les républicains auront
du temps pour se reconstruire a donc
c'est plutôt bien joué je pensais c'est
votre avis aussi
moi j'ai été surpris par sa part sa
prise de parole je le trouve en décalage
parce que si vous écoutez bien ce
qu'elle dit elle et pas du tout en en
association avec marine le pen
d'ailleurs elle a absolument pas dit que
je jouais le pen comme étant la
candidate naturelle du rassembla
nationale en 2022 donc moi ce que je
pense c'est qu'elle avait un timing qui
devait être un peu différent et ce
qu'elle craint c'est que mariani égard
aux aspire énormément d'élus de la
droite républicaine classique en disant
au cas où les gars attendez on l'a fait
avant vous maintenant regarder ce n'est
pas la catastrophe
et eux ils ont une capacité d'attraction
absolument énorme et donc qu'elle se
place entre les deux comme ça je vois
pas aujourd'hui quelle est la
construction politique de ce qu'elle va
proposer le rassemblement national a
gagné sans elle n est pas aller aux
législatives elle n'a pas aidé lors des
européennes et ils ont le même corpus
voir plus d'électeurs que qu'en 2020 pas
tout à fait est que quand qu'en 2017 et
marion maréchal-le pen n'a pas été un
allié de de marine le pen et donc par
rapport à la droite non plus donc là je
sais pas ce qu'elle va leur proposer
si ce n'est de dire je vais accélérer
mon retour sur le devant de la scène et
je remercie pour ses analyses et ses
points de vue on va rester là pour ce
soir la parole à nos internautes
citoyens payeurs qui dit n'y a plus
place pour l heure la république en
marche a trop siphonner à droite chez
les mous et les centristes tout ça entre
guillemets les plus durs iront aux
arènes
babineau qui nous dit il ya quelque
chose de profondément non sincère
antipathique chez wauquiez il n'a plus
jamais été reçue favorablement par les
français le citoyen payeur encore et les
remords ps mort et l'efym hors pc mort à
qui le tour
miss maréchal at on s'entoure sagement
elle et bardella vont prendre du galon
après dix citoyens payeurs et babineau
pense comme vous jacky isabello marion
maréchal parle comme une éditorialiste
l'analyse la situation quand elle devra
assumer ses positions plus compliqué
pour elle les nerfs sont finis ils vont
se dissoudre chez macron la reine et le
nouvel l'ump s10 révoltons-nous je pense
savoir vers où penche le coeur de cet
internaute et flight ça c'est clair
nicolas sarkozy est de loin le meilleur
candidat à la succession de monsieur
vieux quai pour redynamiser l air une
réaction sur ce point-là êtes d'accord
non évidemment non non eh bien il ya
matière le débat comme continue je
rappelle deux choses d'abord la question
sur le figaro.fr existe-t-il un espace
entre la république en marche et le
rassemblement national pour l'instant
vous n'êtes pas encore convaincu riesch
a pour l'instant des internautes pensent
non à 56% d'en avoir qui répondre dans
ce sont les électeurs de l'hérault m où
il se soigne oui et bien vous pouvez
continuer justement à nous le dire en
continuant de chatter sur ce player
c'est à dire à droite de cet écran vous
voyez cette émis cette émission j'ajoute
que jean françois copé est l'invité
d'auditions publiques dans un peu plus
d'une heure maintenant à 19 heures
ici même